how are you guys doing
good how are you wait is that is that
thanos i see
it is yes oh man oh yeah
i already like you you're already
i can see um that you are a fan of
marvel marvel movies and superheroes
uh and the nightmare before christmas i
can see
in the back um and yeah my dad is like a
fan of funko pops he he has a lot of
he even gave a few old ones to me
uh so now i have some in my room
and i um am a fan of princess dresses
unicorns and of course ponies and cats
why wouldn't you be yeah i mean you got
it
yeah i i'm gonna tell you a secret i
gave one of our animals
a yes day today
oh my gosh what's her name this is marlo
and marlo is normally not allowed to be
in the interview room but today he got a
yes day
okay okay got lucky right so i want to
ask you guys a question
um the first day of filming you were
filming the ice cream scene
and i just want to know what is it like
to to
like spend a day or two days eating ice
cream
non-stop it was so much fun it's it's
amazing i mean
they had a spit bucket right but i did
not use it i didn't use the spit bucket
i
it was so much fun am i i i think i had
like
five brain freezes yeah they had a spit
bucket but i only used it for
a tiny little thing um
but otherwise i loved it i when they
called cut i just kept eating because i
loved it so much i can't stop no no no
no
let me finish the scene i love it please
the other thing is you guys filmed a a
huge party scene
with like 25 kids with soapy
foam in a house and i'm just curious
what is it like to basically
be given permission to just throw a huge
party and just
have fun all day filming a house getting
destroyed
it is awesome i mean it was so much fun
i mean the foam was like
probably it was it was higher than
everly in the bathroom
because it was coming up from the
toilets it was higher than everly's head
and i mean it was it was it was so much
fun and that people were sliding down
the steps
they were like they were like jumping in
the phone and the phone they were like
like swimming in the phone it was it was
awesome it was a little scary
because when we were coming down the
stairs i was afraid i would slip
um because i could not see the stairs i
was
uh not ready for what i was seeing
and but the one good thing is that
julian
uh was holding my hand so i wouldn't
slip even if i did
i gotcha that was
very nice of you i i am very curious
since making the movie
have you tried to convince your family
to let you actually have a yes day
or was this something that you did
beforehand
uh you know i actually i have not done
one yet but we are going to do one on
march 20th international yesterday
i'm really really excited i think my
parents are excited i think they're
nervous cited
because like nervous and excited because
they don't know what stuff i'm going to
do
but i think they're just excited just to
spend time with me
nervous and excited a combination too
nerve-sided oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah did you get have you done it
yesterday
no but i'm gonna do one uh march
12 uh the day that yesterday comes out
i think i'll still be in pittsburgh but
it doesn't matter
i don't know if i'm gonna get this
big ass to happen but i want to explode
the house with gummy bears
i think that you will have a lot of fun
if you get to pull this off
i already have to go congratulations on
the movie
good luck with your next interviews
thank you so much